hi and welcome to serverless migration
station i'm wesley from google joined by
martin to summarize you with modernizing
your apps on one of our serverless
compute platforms this time our little
friend porter will take us on the final
leg of our migration to cloud tasks
doing a mixture of optional migrations
more optional migrations with uh why are
we even making this video then
well when modernizing your apps there
are gonna be some steps which are less
critical than others but maybe necessary
at some point so we're here to show our
friends out there how to do them when
the time comes
i suppose you're right
how many of these optional migrations
are we looking at and what are they ah
glad you're a good sport we're doing
three migrations today all optional but
recommended first we're porting from
python 2 to 3. you probably should move
to python 3 since python 2 has been
sunset and that's where the community
has moved to right i mean honestly this
app is already compatible with both
python 2 and 3. so there's really not
much work to be done here
next moving to cloud tasks is also
pretty much a no-op meaning you don't
really need to change anything beyond
the version numbers however this may be
different in future versions for now it
suffices to say that development on
cloud tasks has froze for python 2 hence
why the client library is on version 1
whereas python 3s is on version 2.
finally we know from modules 2 and 3
that cloud ndb is just a migration tool
for python 2 app engine developers from
modules 6 and 10 we know that cloud
firestore is the latest nosql database
solution from google cloud by going
straight there we get to jump over the
cloud datastore migration moving
directly to firestore does require a
completely different project so this
endeavor is optional but more like
building a prototype to see what these
migrations entail and for you to
consider before doing these to your own
apps
okay those all make sense
it's been a while since i've done one of
these migrations before we do the
migration today
can i get a quick review of how we got
here
yep sure martin previously in module 8
we migrated from app engine task queues
to cloud tasks because migrating to
cloud firestore requires a brand new
project you should get more details from
module 6. links to the videos and
codelabs are below so you can catch up
as we're going to pick up where module 8
left off and merge in part of that
module 6 migration sounds good wes uh
you know i'm here to learn all about the
ways to modernize my apps and and get
hands-on experience doing so uh can you
point me to code as well as the codelab
so i can do this migration on my own
time after watching you
of course martin same drill as before
for all of you use your module 8
solution or clone the repo or download
the zip file if you don't have it we'll
start with the module 8 code and finish
with what's in the module 9 repo folder
links to the repo and code lever down
below
so pause here if you need to go get
anything
ready let's dive into these migrations
since we're doing several migrations
with a bunch of code changes you have to
confirm you're starting with a working
module 8 code whether yours or ours if
you're on python 2 double check your lib
folder or blow it away and run the pip
install command to reinstall those
third-party packages into the lib folder
then use gcloud app deploy and confirm
your app engine app outputs the same
most recent visit list and possibly
older visits to delete with a push task
now things look good copy the entire
folder as we're going to make major
changes to it as we will deploy to a
completely different project
first stop app.yaml where modern app
engine doesn't require much for simple
apps like this one the most critical
part is switching from python two to
three and as a result moving from the
first generation to second generation
service
one big change is that web frameworks
must do their own routing this means
that all app handlers have to switch to
auto but if everything is auto you
really don't need them at all especially
since the framework does it so yes you
can remove all app handlers like what we
did but if you've got static files leave
them here because that does not go
through the framework
next the section for built-in
third-party libraries is no longer
needed they now go into requirements.txt
similarly there's no more copying or
self-bundling of non-built-in libraries
you just put them into requirements.txt
and that's it this is covered in a bit
more detail in the module 2 video linked
below for our simple app the net result
is that you can delete all lines except
for the runtime where we're sending it
to python 38 here
since all third-party management is in
requirements.txt
that means no more app engine config
file so delete that too
for requirements.txt we know that all
third-party packages go in here now
version numbers do need a bump because
every library has a final version that
works on python 2. for us this was cloud
tasks 1.5 today the version for python 3
is 2.3 but that too will change
similarly we're switching from cloud ndb
to cloud firestore so this line has to
be completely swapped in python 2 we
self-bundled third party libraries with
pip install but in python 3 don't do
that seriously google takes care of this
when deploying so you don't have to lift
a finger are we liking python 3 yet
anyway that's it for the config files
let's turn to the real work and that's
in main.py
at the top there are two changes one is
that logging in python 3 is easier you
don't need to use python logging just
print to standard out so remove that
import
next we're switching from cloud ndb to
cloud firestore so swap that client
library import finally instantiate the
correct api clients
next all of the constants for task
queues stay the same but we have to add
a new one the queue path variable is the
fully qualified queue path name
one difference between app engine task
queues and cloud tasks we didn't cover
last time in module 8 is that when using
app engine push cues the default queue
was automatically created by app engine
but that's not the case with cloud tasks
which is independent of app engine with
cloud tasks you need to create all of
your push cues including the default
queue if you want one and to do so you
need the path name up to but not
including the queue name so that's what
the path prefix is
for store visit the changes you see are
the differences between cloud ndb and
cloud firestore cloud firestore doesn't
have a data model nor does it require
context managers and with statements in
ndb we refer to data records as entities
of a certain kind while firestore has
documents belonging to collections
regardless of all this know that store
visit has one job it creates a new data
record with the connecting client ip as
well as their web client or user agent
one last note ndb automatically adds a
time stamp when an object is created but
it must be done explicitly in firestore
since app engine task queues create a
default queue by default we didn't need
a function like create q if in our
module 8 main.py
before creating a task
this function is used to check if we
need to create the queue which is only
done if it doesn't already exist
next is fetch visits at the top querying
for the most recent visits has to change
from cloud ndb to cloud firestore again
the functionality is identical the
differences are just between how ndb
does it versus firestorm
for the next section fortunately cloud
tasks doesn't change between version 1
and version 2 of the client library so
no real updates to your code are needed
as to how the task is created
now the logging call is to change to
print
and we have to add that check to make
sure the queue exists before adding the
task
now you may ask why we didn't do this
before with cloud tas and module 8 and
again it's because the module 7 code
used app engine task keys where the
default key was automatically created
now it wasn't until this app where we
had to use cloud firestore requiring us
to create a completely brand new project
that we discovered that we had to make
our own default queue
let's skip over this new function delete
docs for just a moment and dive into the
trim task handler we saw just a moment
ago from fetch visits how querying is
identical but ndb and firestore do it
slightly differently the same applies to
this query looking for visits older than
the oldest one shown
one subtle difference is that ndb has
convenient batching like a keys only
query since i don't need to look at the
data plus a delete multi function for
batch delete in firestore you would
issue a regular query then loop through
and delete them one at a time or use a
batch delete since i want to log all the
objects deleted i move the deletion loop
into delete docs a generator that yields
the id for each document deleted so i
can count how many were deleted and log
that back in trim
otherwise i logged that there weren't
any old records to delete the main get
handler doesn't change at all so we're
skipping that
so overall that was probably one of the
more intense migrations so far in this
series if you look at you know how much
code was deleted updated or new code was
added
simple migrations are great for teaching
but generally not as realistic so the
goal was to try and make it more
lifelike
we actually forgot one last migration of
porting this app from python 2-3 but
don't worry i'm not going to keep this
video running too long i deliberately
crafted all of the sample apps to run on
both python 2 and 3 without any
modifications or compatibility libraries
so reporting part is already done
now that everyone's on python 3 you've
got no more pip install so just run
gcloud app deploy to confirm it works as
advertised making sure that you change
to your new project before doing so
because we're doing more migrations in
this module the chances of doing
something wrong is higher so let the
logs help you or you can check out our
solution in the module 9 repo folder to
compare your answers with ours alright
let's go back to the main presentation
wow lots of different migrations and
things to consider
if i wanted to get more information
about migrating my app engine app from
python 2 to 3 where should i look
yeah the best place is the python 2-3
app engine migration guide it links to
all the individual pages for migrating
to cloud data store cloud tasks and all
the other standalone services
okay and same for cloud ndb and cloud
firestore i'd like to review both to get
a better idea of the differences between
them
do you have any links for them yup sure
thing while we don't have a formal cloud
ndb product page nor an ndb2 firestore
migration guide your best resources are
the client library docs for both as well
as the general cloud firestore docs
ah yeah those look really useful uh also
now that we're checking for and creating
our own task queues i need to read up on
those gotcha
well all the links mentioned here plus
the cloudtask client library and general
docs are down below for your reading
pleasure great thanks for those wes are
we doing any more task queue migrations
ah nope well this is the last of the
task q miniseries summarizing today's
adventure we ported our app from python
2 to 3. we moved from cloud ndb to cloud
firestore combining modules 3 and 6 and
we've revved up to the latest cloudtask
client library including adding new code
to create the default cube something we
didn't need before since we were still
running on our original project where
the app engine task queue system
automatically created that default queue
cool
what other migrations should i consider
for my app engine app
well since we've already done cloud ndb
cloud data store and firestore you're
done with all the database stuff now if
you're thinking about containerizing
your app engine apps to run on cloud run
we'll check out modules four and five
finally if you've got a tiny app that's
just one function or a giant app you
want to break up into microservices
those sound like really good use cases
for cloud functions and that migration
is covered in module 11. there are other
migrations coming so look out for blog
posts as well as checking the repo from
time to time for more migration content
thanks wes i'll check those out and
thank all of you for sticking with us
for all these different migrations this
is wesley on behalf of martin and porter
and we'll see you at the next migration
station or on another serverless
expedition soon
[Music]